[Musique]
les enfants il fait un de ces vents ce
soir dans le ciel je te le feu lui votre
pull bolt on va vite voir pimprenelle et
nicolas je suis sûr qu'ils attendent
avec impatience le jour petit propos
mais ne traîne pas trop mes petits amis
sont ici
bon froid ou sorties ils se sont cachés
les quotas coucou
non il ne faut pas là
à
du coup que je suis bête ils sont
derrière jerry tron qu'est-ce que
j'étais revers le pot au lait petits
brigands
ils étaient cachés d'un jugement dont tu
as fait à part yens 1,9 à ce type à
promenade puis c'est un championnat peu
avec ma chair mon nom je vous en prie je
ne sais pas
[Musique]
merci autres au vasco china north d'une
attaque on pas on va chanter notre
chanson oh là je viens de surtout cédric
où les contenances c'est pour toi
[Musique]
l'udc ou mois ci la fin de la journée
vélo moment de ce projet nous faisons
comme nos amis ils s'en vont tous ou lit
non c'est long aussi sur son nuage
certains moments le marchand de sable à
temps il nous dira fermez vos yeux et
dormait tous les deux non sommes bien
dans notre lit nos emplois les propos
non j'engrange voit un peu les plaisirs
je vais m'endormir
non je vais m'endormir sa voix nous les
plaisirs le petit une mineure
nous souhaitions corpos nicolas
pimprenelle en voilà des façons si vous
faites encore les vilains ne viendront
plus et puisque vous avez été tellement
méchant avec ce pauvre nounours demain
ne viendront pas vous voir
allez vous coucher tout seul je lui
chaut pas trop son terrible secret oui
mon pauvre nounours mais moi mon petit
doigt me dit qu'il y à d'autres enfants
qui font aussi des caprices et qui ne
vont pas se coucher tout de suite s'il
continue nous ne viendrons pu les voir
où vous ou alors allez vite au dodo
à dimanche une bonne nuit pour 2010
[Musique]